okay okay [ __ ] this is channel number
5 and it's psychobabble here the price
of oil so let's see what let's see what
we got there here [ __ ] welcome to
challenge 5 make sure you don't don't
overproduce okay and some sort of energy
of consequence you what's the deal with
them and this challenge must produce a
thousand electricity and less than 100
sickness oh [ __ ] okay okay it's gonna be
interesting and do the classic the
classic setup okay I can't get get it I
got good gets on that water go mmm [ __ ]
any lectures today [ __ ] a all right
yes I gotta get this i guess i need some
[ __ ] houses to make some labor you
know you know mm-hmm I love chocolate I
love chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate I love chocolate I love
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
guess who's going on here why some
[ __ ] money unless joint baby and it's
a money baby no no no no no no no no no
no no Nana wait where the [ __ ] are all
the stuff that makes money excuse me I
have a [ __ ] i make money here
um didn't give me anything I can wreak
money right office now
now the oil tank makes money mm-hmm
inorganic waste and sickness okay [ __ ]
and I get rid of sickness of the clinic
shut what are we the [ __ ] I ok ok take
sickness
ok sickness going down no it has not
that's good that's good news that means
things I got horribly so I'll see this
again ok sickness has gone down now now
I'll just going down yes need some need
some [ __ ] youth ok ok ok you like
that you like guys now we have four more
[ __ ] oil
hmm where's the electricity how fast it
going up okay let's just do a swung it
fast
ok got seconds to go down thank God and
we are making a [ __ ] ton of electricity
ok I'll [ __ ] people to walk on that real
quick turn to road well anyways um
that's this mission I'm basically going
to I mean so at this rate it just it's
going to hit the mission electricity I'm
go you of course make things make it go
faster that's basically it so I want to
fast forward with st. i'm also going to
build which I make it go faster so
that's it thanks for watching thank you